baby news those guilty pleas have just
been announced JP Morgan City with
Barclays and the Royal Bank of Scotland
all pleading guilty to currency rigging
and UBS will plead guilty to
manipulating interest rates we are
learning more now about the penalties
and the fines they are facing Julie
Hyman is in the newsroom with the
headlines well Olivia the totality of
these fines by these banks 5.8 billion
dollars to settle with the United States
five of these banks are pleading guilty
to criminal charges of the banks that
you mentioned four of them citigroup
jpmorgan Barclays and Royal Bank of
Scotland are pleading guilty to
conspiring to manipulate currency
markets UBS is pleading guilty to
manipulating LIBOR and who are these
settlements within the u.s. the Justice
Department the CFTC and the Federal
Reserve Barclays also reaching a
settlement with the New York financial
regulators been loskis a New York
financial regulator over that currency
manipulation and Barclays is also
reaching a settlement with the UK
regulator in terms of getting a little
more granular here and what we know
right now and we will likely get more
details from the various regulatory
agencies on these fines but what we know
right now about the Justice Department
find specifically our settlements excuse
me we should say a city core Citigroup
has agreed to pay a fine of 925 million
dollars Barclays fine again with the DOJ
will be 710 million dollars JP Morgan
550 million dollars and RBS 395 million
dollars of course UBS had already come
out this morning with the details of its
settlements that it is paying it's going
to be paying a total of 203 million
dollars with the DOJ and then 342
million dollars to the Federal Reserve
so those are some of the details that we
know already on these various
settlements and fines